they're about 350 million shoes that go
in landfills each year when 1.5 billion
people don't have a pair of footwear
your focus can either be on the problems
or the Gori so our focus is always on
the go so we never feel any challenges
[Music]
our basic raw materials old shoes and
using them we upcycle these old shoes
into slippers and then we donate them to
people in need and also retain them so
these shoes come to us free of cost from
all over India carpets are partnering
with us a lot of schools clubs they give
us these old shoes then we dismantle
them and make them into upcycle slippers
and every pair that we donate we get
$3.00 on it we also have a retail range
where just by buying a pair people can
show support to the environment they can
show support to the social good so we
never thought that we'll be
entrepreneurs or social entrepreneurs it
was just an accident that we came up
with the idea and then built it up from
there we never had I need speedruns of
manufacturing no entrepreneurship
background also at 20 we were we found
us as running a factory where 100 units
were being made in a day so that was a
challenge but it was sort of fun I think
when I look back those are the actually
good times the feedback has been
excellent because it's a very noble
cause you're not doing it for any sort
of to become very rich so to become very
famous there's some genuine intent some
genuine problem that we started with and
eventually built it into a venture and
people realize that I'm actually got
delighted when I got to know that I made
it to the folks they shall 30 under 30
legs it opens a lot of doors for us in
terms of more sponsorship and it's a
title that we carry lifelong and it's
sort of a one lifetime achievement and a
one time goal which we've achieved the
goal is to have a pan India presence to
have stores all across India in the next
five years and on the donation side we
want to touch a million pairs being
refurbished and donated and about 10 to
15 scale centres in India
you